one of the biggest UI changes coming to
Android curious gestural navigation you
may have already seen various gestures
for navigation on some of our partners
devices Android q is supporting a new
out-of-the-box navigation experience
navigation gestures are supported as a
new mode separate from the traditional
three button experience in the bottom
nav bar this lets your app use the
entire screen which provides a more
immersive display experience Android q
has gestures for going home and going
back swiping up from the bottom edge
takes the user to the home screen
swiping inverts anywhere on the left or
right edges takes the user back to the
previous screen with these two guesses
your app can take advantage of the
valuable screen real estate on the
bottom of the display however if your
app uses gestures or has controls in the
system yester areas it might create
conflicts with the system-wide gestures
for example if your app relies on
gestures for sliders or draggable items
in any of the system gesture areas your
users might accidentally trigger a
navigation gesture this results in a
broken experience in your app there are
two guest your conflicts your app might
encounter the first conflict is with the
swipe up gesture on the bottom edge of
the screen which takes the user to the
home screen you should avoid having any
critical controls rely on vertical swipe
gesture in the bottom parts of your app
because the home gesture is designed to
be a reliable escape mechanism for users
and will always get priority for touch
events examples of UI conflicts with the
home guest you are bottom draggable
sheets or other swipe up to perform
actions to steer clear of the bottom
swipe conflict we edit window inserts
that get mandatory system gesture
insects which returns all swipe
recognition thresholds for the device
using this information apps can shift
conflicting content from the edges of
the screen the second conflict is with
the edge swipe gesture which
the user back the system back yester
occupies the entire length of the left
and right screen edges so apps should
make sure that he touch and motion
functionality is in stolen by system
back gesture examples of interaction
conflicts with the back gesture include
drawers sliders sheets and other
controls which require a swipe or drag
to perform an action in order to handle
touch events at the edges of the screen
apps can tell the system which areas
they need to exclude from the back
gesture with the new gesture exclusion
Rex API and cue if back gesture
interferes with your app controls use
the gesture exclusion Rex API to create
gesture exclusion zones for the controls
that might be affected on the other hand
do not disable the Bacchus turbine
against your exclusion zone which spans
entire edge of the screen this creates a
broken non consistent behavior with the
system and other apps the Neve API is a
part of the view class which expects a
list of wrecked objects that represent
history exclusion zones this API lets
your app intercept horizontal swipes
only between the desired areas the
gesture exclusion rekts API call should
be performed in the own layout or on
draw methods of the view as shown in
this example
draw a layout and seekbar components
already have this opt-out behavior
built-in so no additional work is needed
other than updating the jetpack
dependencies and all built against the
new SDK respectively and that's it to
ensure the best user experience make
sure the gestures in your app do not
conflict with system-wide gestures if
they do use system gesture exclusion
recs API to fix any problems before
targeting your app to Android cue if
you're interested in gestural navigation
make sure you also watch the edge to
edge their bite which is linked in the
notes blog thank you for watching make
sure to subscribe to the channel for
more awesome Android videos see you next
time
[Music]